cults GM Chris Ballard who has been
around professional football for years
very candid yesterday in a video
conference about his own ability to kind
of wall off and compartmentalize and
live his life as a white American
without fully appreciating the
perspective the struggles and the
discomfort that minorities have to deal
with every single day here's Ballad from
yesterday I can't sit here and remain
silent because that's exactly what we've
done I mean every time our black
community screams and yells for help we
have to end social injustice and racial
inequality we have to end the police
violence against our black communities
you know black lives matter I don't
understand why that's so freaking hard
for the white community to say black
lives matter
I've been ignorant I've been in debt to
the real problem and I'm ashamed of that
I just came to the realization here over
the last 10 days with some really hard
difficult conversations that we've had
as an organization as a team with my
family with my sons and I've been
ignorant to the real pump you see this
is not a black problem this is a white
problem this is a this is an issue that
we have to talk about
we can't we can't sugarcoat it
we can't sugarcoat our way out of this
we can't go back into our bubble because
that's what we've always done we've
always gone right back into our ball
into our bubbles and we've never really
listened
we haven't listened I haven't listened
we haven't listened as a country white
America refuses to listen we want to
keep things the same and it can't
oh we're gonna pin you down the same
pass what continuing down and that has
to change and nothing will change until
we do that I'm ashamed of that that was
awesome and I already had a ton of
respect for Chris Powell to the general
manager the Colts but that's the kind of
candor that's the kind of and you could
you could see he's upset with himself
for allowing so much time to go by
without waking up to what is happening
in front of him what is happening around
him and it is easy for us to get caught
up in our lives the work that's in front
of us the family issues we deal with the
things we like to spend our free time
doing days become weeks weeks become
months months become years and and we
like it when things don't don't pierce
through our routine well yeah at the
time where we have to we have to break
from our routine we have to be the ones
who tear the walls down and pay
attention to what's going on with other
people and and I think that what Ballard
said was spot-on and it's very inspiring
and I hope we all take it to heart yeah
it's the saying like can we just get
back to normal that's that's our
reaction whenever there is some big
story or you know the pandemic is also
part of this but you know it has led to
some frustration of can we get back to
normal can we get back to normal well no
we can't that's the point is that it
will we need to not be known it needs to
not get back to normal it needs to be
uncomfortable and things need to change
and so that's our initial reaction I
think a lot of times like oh well if
something's hard let's just get back to
normal and that's not gonna happen here
and that's a good thing and that's a
good thing and if you felt uncomfortable
in the last week and a half that's a
good thing that means that maybe you're
thinking about this
and it clear that Chris Ballard is doing
that and all these devices that have
been used in the past to force things
back to normal I think are going to be
failing miserably we mentioned earlier
stick to sports no one no one is giving
that any credence anymore
the whole idea of don't disrespect the
flag or the military and that's what the
conversation is about that wall has come
down the different things that get
thrown at me all the time you're woke oh
good
good now you should be too right social
justice warrior how is that a bad term
that people truck god forbid that
there's something be somebody who is
sufficiently motivated to go on the
offensive to try to make things better
to try to achieve social justice for all
these things these labels that people
use to kind of smack folks down and get
them to quit talking about issues so
they can go back to normal so they can
retreat to their bubble so there can be
undisturbed and not uncomfortable by the
things going on around them that those
do it's that that to me it's laughable
how quickly those defenses have
disintegrated in the wake of what's
happened the last 10 days yeah but it
took a long time Mike I mean that's the
thing is that in 2016 I keep going back
to 2016 but this was a an issue that was
put in front of America in 2016 in a
sports lens with Colin Kaepernick and
it's happened before obviously there's
been some great protests before some
great people who spoke it up before but
this was when it was the hot-button
issue it was a national issue that
everyone was talking about and all those
things worked Mike so it's not that far
it looks four years removed so it's uh I
think there's there's an element of it's
it's moving in the right sort of things
that feel like they move in the right
direction and yeah I know that this last
week at half has been sad and tragic a
lot of ways and obviously George boy
like that video is is almost impossible
to watch because of how sad and tragic
it is but there's also been some really
good things that have come out of this
and it feels like there's been some
all victories and carrying that momentum
forward is what it's all about I think
in recent years it's been just a quiet
gradual shifting of the tectonic plates
what's going on over the last week and a
half as an earthquake and aftershocks
that will last until people are
satisfied that there is true change and
it's not something's gonna go away
quickly I feel like it is a permanent
adjustment to our reality this is the
second kind of permanent adjustment to
our reality that we've had this year
from the virus now to this where I think
that whether you like it or not and if
you don't like it get out of the way
change is coming and the change is
overdue and I feel like enough people
are motivated enough people are awake
enough people are willing to get out of
their own bubbles to recognize that we
are still very far away from being the
nation that was envisioned 244 years ago
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports